with the envoys are officially hosted in
Saudi Arabia for the first time since
the War Began many see this as a major
step towards peace in Yemen it took
years of diplomatic effort by
neighboring Oman but the full agenda of
the talks and who will participate isn't
clear
many are surprised that the U.N
recognized government in Exile isn't
taking part
so far it's Saudi Arabia trying to reach
a settlement with the houthis
the healthy demands include lifting The
saudi-led Siege to allow full reopening
of houthi-controlled ports and Sana
airports
payment of wages of public servants
under houthi rule from oil revenues
rebuilding efforts and the timeline for
foreign forces to quit Yemen
or the delegation go to any talks they
go and they are willing actually for any
peace and they are willing to end the
war but now actually is in the hand of
the Saudi Arabia if they want peace in
Yemen they should expect business Saudi
Arabia if they will continue the
blockade they should expect major attack
on the oil infrastructure Riyadh hasn't
announced its own list of conditions
though and it's not clear to what extent
it's going to comply with healthy
demands a comprehensive piece a lasting
piece is not likely to result from this
visit anyway in fact if anything there
may be signals here that there is a kind
of resignation on the part of all the
key players Regional and international
that
um perhaps the divisions in Yemen are
are here to stay
that each side has given up on their
maximal goals
Saudi Arabia has been trying to get out
of Yemen for some time
a Saudi Iran deal brokered by China
earlier this year was seen as a step in
that direction
comes after nearly a decade of fighting
against Iran backed with militia Who
removed the legitimate government from
power in 2014 and took over the capital
San and most of Northern Yemen by force
the purpose of the Saudi campaign was to
reverse that situation
but that goal wasn't achieved and the
war led to hundreds of thousands losing
their lives and the major humanitarian
disaster
following the peace deal with Iran in
March Saudi Arabia conducted a major
prisoner swap with houthis involving
hundreds of soldiers on both sides the
U.S has welcomed the new round of
negotiations Iran is understood to be on
board too but many believe that for any
final solution to the conflict the
yemenis themselves need to feel
represented across the board Muhammad
al-jazeera